[Música]
la conaie la principal organización
indígena de ecuador pidió radicalizar
las protestas este miércoles luego de
que su líder leonidas iza fuera detenido
la policía señaló que isa buscaba
recrudecer la violencia mientras que su
defensa anunció que presentó un recurso
para solicitar su inmediata liberación
en brasil las autoridades informaron que
detuvieron a un segundo sospechoso
relacionado con la desaparición del
periodista británico don phillips y el
indigenista bruno araujo pereira ambos
fueron vistos por última vez hace más de
una semana y expertos brasileños
realizan exámenes forenses a material
orgánico hallado cerca del punto donde
se perdió su rastro
en colombia unas 500 organizaciones
sociales presentaron un informe del
último año de gestión en materia de
derechos humanos seguridad e
implementación del acuerdo de paz del
saliente presidente iván duque el texto
indica que la inseguridad la presencia
de grupos armados y el paramilitarismo
aumentaron exponencialmente
a ustedes gracias por continuar con
nosotros en france 24 y valentina torres
sánchez y es un gusto acompañarlos
iniciamos en ecuador donde la conaie la
principal organización indígena del país
anunció que sus integrantes marcharán
hacia las principales ciudades para
radicalizar la protesta tras la
detención de leonidas iza el líder de la
organización de acuerdo con la policía
hizo fue capturado en flagrancia cuando
bloqueaba una vía y supuestamente estaba
incentivando un recrudecimiento de la
violencia los indígenas rechazan el alza
de precios en el país y las políticas
económicas del gobierno de guillermo
lasso andrés tapia dirigente de
comunicación de la confederación de
nacionalidades indígenas de la amazonía
ecuatoriana confenaie que también
participa en las protestas nos explicó
los próximos pasos que tomarán para
presionar por sus pedidos
el momento se mantiene medida de hecho
en 14 provincias
es el país es decir más de un 60 por
ciento esto quiere decir acciones como
cierres de vías en el caso de la
amazonía desde donde me encuentro en la
troncal amazónica que cruza desde el eje
vial de toda la amazonía entre otras
medidas que se han tomado a nivel
territorial cuando decimos radicalizar
significa que se van a afianzar este
tipo de medidas de hecho incluso en
torno a las ciudades capitales
principales de las distintas ciudades y
no se descarta tampoco una movilización
hacia la capital de quito sí pues no en
las próximas horas prácticamente no se
libera a la unidad y son
en brásil manifestantes se reunieron
demandando respuestas sobre la
desaparición del periodista británico
don phillips y el experto indigenista
bruno araújo pereira su rastro se perdió
hace más de una semana en el río y taco
ahí en el occidente del país y los
hechos siguen llenos de interrogantes a
la policía informó que detuvo a un
segundo sospechoso presuntamente
relacionado con los hechos previamente
se había informado del hallazgo de dos
cadáveres y el embajador de brasil en
londres lo comunicó a la familia del
británico sin embargo el martes el
diplomático se disculpó por transmitir
información incorrecta
donde están tom phillips y bruno pereyra
en brasilia un grupo de manifestantes
exige justicia y respuestas por la
desaparición del periodista británico
thomas phillips y el experto indigenista
brasileño bruno pereyra
es el nutriente es uno de los nuestros
los que desapareció estaba amenazado no
sabemos lo que pudo pasar pero esperamos
lo mejor
miembros de la fundación nacional del
indio funai convocaron a una
movilización después de las
declaraciones de su propio presidente
quien dijo que la pareja no tenía
permiso para ingresar al valle de javarí
y lo acusaron de no garantizar la
seguridad de los trabajadores
necesitamos un cambio lo que está
pasando en funai es decir el
desmantelamiento la desprotección de las
tierras indígenas el fomento de la
violencia en las áreas indignas
el rastro se perdió hace más de una
semana a lo largo de un tramo remoto del
río y ta kwai en el extremo occidental
de brasil cerca de la frontera con
colombia y perú
en la zona miembros del grupo indígena
uruguaya y oficiales de la policía
seguían buscando en su último reporte
dijeron que las tareas se acercaban a su
final después de que descubrieran
pertenencias de los hombres cerca del
último sitio donde fueron vistos lo que
concentró las tareas en un perímetro
menor entretanto la policía federal
brasileña dijo que esperaba concluir
esta semana el análisis forense de una
de las muestras de sangre recolectadas
en la embarcación de un hombre
sospechoso de estar involucrado
previamente se había informado del
hallazgo de dos cadáveres
pereira viajaba en una investigación con
philips un reportero independiente que
ha escrito para the gardian y el
'washington post' y estaba trabajando en
un libro sobre la amazonía se
encontraban en una remota zona selvática
que alberga la mayor cantidad de
indígenas no contactados del mundo y un
lugar de paso de bandas traficantes
ilegales
unas 500 organizaciones sociales
presentaron el informe hambre y guerra
el legado del aprendiz en el que evalúan
la gestión del último año del presidente
saliente de colombia iván duque a poco
menos de dos meses de dejar el cargo el
documento hace duras críticas al
mandatario en cuanto a garantías de
derechos humanos y la implementación del
acuerdo de paz más temprano hablamos con
alberto yepes coordinador del
observatorio de derechos humanos y
derecho internacional humanitario de la
coordinación colombia-europa-estados
unidos quien nos dijo desde su
perspectiva que no hizo el gobierno
duque
pues lo que no hizo el gobierno fue
implementar los compromisos que en
materia de seguridad y otros compromisos
traía el acuerdo de paz el gobierno
decidió reemplazar los contenidos del
acuerdo de paz por un programa
denominado paz con legalidad que es
básicamente la proyección de su propia
estrategia de seguridad y defensa y que
consiste básicamente en la
militarización de los territorios y no
concentrarse en la seguridad de los
líderes sociales de las organizaciones y
las zonas más afectadas por el conflicto
y esto llevó a una expansión de grupos
ilegales especialmente grupos
paramilitares que iniciaron una racha de
atentados contra los liderazgos otros
llegan
que ha venido creciendo en estos cuatro
años no solamente atentados contra
líderes sociales sino masacre es
desplazamiento confinamiento
reclutamiento forzado
de 500 indicadores que han que han
llevado a una verdadera crisis
humanitaria en una situación dramática
que entrega el país el gobierno del
presidente y bando
por este incumplimiento la asamblea
nacional de nicaragua autorizó el
ingreso de tropas barcos y aeronaves
rusas a petición de urgencia del
presidente daniel ortega el mandatario
aseguró que las tropas y el armamento
que lleguen al país tendrán el objetivo
de luchar contra el delito tanto en el
mar caribe como en el océano pacífico
los legisladores también ratificaron el
ingreso por seis meses a partir de julio
de personal y aeronaves de los ejércitos
de cuba estados unidos méxico venezuela
y varios países centroamericanos
en argentina la policía allanó las
habitaciones donde se hospedan los
tripulantes venezolanos e iraníes del
avión que se encuentra retenido en el
aeropuerto internacional de ezeiza las
autoridades continúan bloqueando la
salida de la aeronave que se encuentra
varada desde el 6 de junio cuando fueron
confiscados los pasaportes de los 5
iraníes que hacen parte de la
tripulación
y en españa se están registrando altas
temperaturas sin haber iniciado siquiera
el verano todo debido a una ola de calor
proveniente del norte de áfrica que está
azotando gran parte del país y se espera
que dure hasta el 18 de junio alva
santana nos amplía
calor mucho calor en españa' con la ola
de calor a más temprana del país en 40
años y la peor en al menos 20 los
ciudadanos buscan un lugar en el que
refugiarse pues mirad de esa clima tal
porque si este caso hubiese sido más de
allá no hubiésemos que el cambio sea tan
brusco lo hubiésemos acostumbrado ya y
bueno más o menos es lo que tenemos aquí
del verano hasta noviembre con las
temperaturas de hasta 43 grados celsius
en el sur y también intensas en el
interior del país este fenómeno se debe
a una nube de aire caliente proveniente
del norte de áfrica y es peligroso para
la salud de la población puede provocar
desde desmayos náuseas y trastornos
cardíacos hasta convulsiones unas
condiciones con las que trabajar se
vuelve una tarea muy difícil no sabemos
cómo vamos a hacer
es lo que hay de un momento aguantamos
pero creo que
y es que cada vez hay más olas de calor
en el sur de europa un fenómeno natural
que aunque no está directamente
relacionado con la crisis climática y el
calentamiento global sino es su carácter
extremo y prematuro según los expertos
un aumento de la media se traduce
precisamente en eso en una mayor
probabilidad de alcanzar valores
extremos por lo tanto es a esa mayor
probabilidad se traduce en que realmente
hay más horas de calor se prevé que esta
ola de calor a persiste en españa' al
menos hasta el 19 de junio unos días
antes del inicio del verano el 21 de
junio y la noche de este 14 a 15 de
junio está acompañada por la súper luna
de fresa la primera de tres lunas llenas
que se verán en el fin de la primavera y
la temporada de verano un dron grabó al
satélite natural de la tierra detrás del
antiguo templo griego más grande y
brillante de lo normal en dubai también
se pudo ver desde diferentes puntos y el
líbano se elevó sobre la capital beirut
se trata de la segunda vez en este año
que se registra una súper luna
el nombre de luna de fresa en relación
con la maduración de las fresas en el
mes de junio
es todo por el momento en france 24 a
ustedes les agradecemos su sintonía
volvemos en breve con más información
[Música]